remember all those conspiracy theories
about how barack obama was not going to
leave the White House after his second
presidential term was over he was a some
said going to declare martial law and
suspend the 2016 election or he was
going to violate every check and balance
that our country has in order to
maintain control and then of course
Barack Obama had never mentioned
anything that would suggest he was going
to do that and he peacefully left on his
helicopter turning over control to
president Donald Trump and if there was
ever a case to be made for an exception
in turning over control to such a
buffoon it kind of would have been
Donald Trump and yep Iraq Obama as
predicted by any rational clear thinking
person very very peaceful he left
Donald Trump has now retweeted the
suggestion that he should get a six year
term instead of a four year term because
he was robbed of two years from his
presidency by the Muller probe and he
referred to those two years as being
stolen from him not I know you're saying
wait what's Stalin not stolen Stalin but
we'll get to that in a second there's
this disgusting guy named Jerry Falwell
Jr he's the son of the late Jerry
Falwell who in my mind is most known for
blaming 911 on abortionists and gays and
Jerry Falwell Jr tweeted and Donald
Trump subsequently retweeted a tweet
which says after the best week ever for
Donald Trump
no obstruction no collusion New York
Times admits Barack Obama did spy on his
campaign and the economy is soaring I
now support reparations Trump should
have two years added to his first term
as payback for time stolen by this
corrupt failed coup so first of all no
that's not constitutional and if we care
about that then the answer to this is
obviously no but secondly this is a
political statement from a guy whose
church is tax-exempt because churches
aren't supposed to be doing politics now
is doing Paul
dicks on Twitter a violation of the
nonprofit charter that churches have I
don't know for sure the legal experts
would have to fight it out but the IRS
should definitely be looking into this
but Trump sees it and he retweets it and
then he decides to take the idea of
those two stolen years to the next level
Falwell tweeted that on Saturday night
Sunday Donald Trump tweets despite the
tremendous success that I have had as
president including perhaps the greatest
economy and most successful first two
years of any president in history a
laughable claim they have stolen two
years of my our presidency collusion
delusion that we will never be able to
get back the stalin typo is so
ridiculous and so embarrassing ly
hilarious that Donald Trump ended up the
leading the tweet but fortunately we
have it for you anyway
but let's get back to the primary issue
here because I the the stalin typo is
funny
but there's actually a really important
thing here is there a chance Trump will
try to not relinquish control of the
White House whenever this national
nightmare ultimately ends either in two
years or in six years Nancy Pelosi is
now concerned that that something Trump
will do she's concerned that if it's a
very marginal a very small margin by
which Trump loses in 2020 Trump will not
relinquish power or will try not to
Trump has actually said that the only
way Democrats can beat him in 2020 is
voter fraud he said he likes the idea of
the possibility of doing president for
life in the US the way that China has
put in place that possibility under the
current administration and we would
quote maybe try it sometime so as I've
said before I believe that law
enforcement agencies of the United
States will not allow Trump to stay in
power beyond his actual electoral
mandate period but every single person
who when Barack Obama was president was
stoking the fears of Obama's not going
to leave why are you now silent because
there was nothing to suggest that was
something Barack Obama was going to do
Trump has actually floated the
narratives that he can't lose unless
there's foul play that combined with his
malignant narcissism and weaponized
ignorant actually gets us closer than
Obama ever was to a situation where the
president
tries to retain control beyond when he's
actually elected but then the most
disturbing part of it is tons of Trump's
followers agree that he should get an
extra two years the most important thing
here is not Trump's misspelling of
stolen a Stalin it's not that Trump has
actually floated this idea of you know
maybe president for life would be nice
and I can only lose by voter fraud Trump
has a significant number of these
brown-nosing sycophants who think it's
reasonable for Trump to get an extension
to his presidential term they claim to
be constitutional conservatives they
pray at the altar of the Constitution as
if it is a sacred text and then of
course for Trump they make an exception
and this may end up being particularly
relevant when it comes to the statute of
limitations on obstruction of justice
Donald Trump is very heavily
incentivized to stay in power for as
long as possible by legal means by
borderline means or by illegal means not
that it would be successful but he's
incentivized to do it specifically to
avoid indictment on obstruction when he
is alone no longer president will be
talking with some legal experts upcoming
on the show about that and the statute
of limitations on obstruction of justice
and that very important footnote in
Robert Muller's report I believe it's
footnote 1090 or 10 91 which says
whether or not a president is impeached
for the stuff in the Moller report that
would not preclude or be a substitute
for indictment once the president is no
longer president of the United States
this is the slide towards it's this
gradual slide towards despotism or I
think better said would be despotism
hopefully we prevent it we know it's
what Trump would love let me know what
you think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
we will take a quick break
what a big news weekend which I am glad
to be here to tell you about upcoming
today's program was made possible in
part by better help.com slash Pakman
better help is an online service
gives you access to your own experienced
fully licensed therapist via phone video
and text when you see a therapist in
person in their office it can take three
weeks on average before you're able to
get in for your first appointment but
with better help you're matched with a
therapist who fits your needs within
just 24 hours and you get the same
professional service and the best part
is that better help is less expensive
than seeing a therapist in person as
well plus you will have totally
unlimited access to the therapist you
can talk to them whenever you want on
your phone or computer and because
better help believes in what they do
they also have a full money-back
guarantee if you're not happy with the
service you'll get a full refund no
questions asked all of their therapists
go through an extensive vetting process
and are required to have at least three
years of experience before joining
better help so you know you're getting
someone who's fully qualified to help
you but if you don't think that your
therapist is a good fit better help lets
you switch to someone new at anytime if
you've been thinking about getting
involved with therapy you should really
check out better help just click the
link underneath this video